サムドタイトルを見たいなうわ感じかなぁ
堂々と最初があります始めちょっと出てるじゃんうわぁ
ran
lng 社長山はい初めましてあのーありませんが
10月 udg 社長さんねージャガー
どうぞ持ったでしたそもそも嫉妬ぞ色いや should 例ですよ見てる層違いそう
じゃない確かにでね
雑感家だと思うんですけどレペゼン地球さあも言えるんでがオレオレ
これから夏
廊下がー aa 女優ねあなた文見てる人がまずここ所はないだろうと思ってたんで
そうやって俺が思って栄光コーヒーを個並べると思ってなかったムーヴから止められ a
コラボしたやっぱ肇社長のファンとかに叩かれ8位でしょ結構多いけどちゃいる
リンガー
したいとかめっちゃ
水から言えローションでサッカーがシュッときちゃってやって食べダンテに初期のなん
かあのイベント数にやりブスブス佐々のコーラともすんねああこれだけどちょっと強度
のですね人まで一気話してみますはぜんざい今日はの初代弁なんで雑菌コミュ障って
結構大丈夫
おしゃれなんたらちょっと感じ取ったか本当ですね有効だった
ゾンないコミュ障じゃないいや意外とヒットして見やすいラウンドでやっぱ
長にあれ dj 者城東肇社長へどうぞ社長の社長が
結構来ていしかも前としそう26なんですよねお返し
しかも ab型りえっいるあー指がぞね座0型
face 祭礼りっ子すごいこの頭に生えと共通点があるんやすごい
1本目は何気なくさえやはりくらさきほど飲まないベッツの
栗メイズがあるめっちゃの上を持たないのことあんまり知らないと思うんですよ
いやまずねえ紹介してもらったの光くんないああああああああねあの
詐欺師やハァハァ言っちゃっを交え紹介書士
だってえらいつないでもらってそこではじぇねーみたいな
33つないでいただいたという感じで
dj 冊終わり冬通話するたですか俺
1年結構最近だね結構最近アロ
youtube はじめたのがその8月1日だけどその前からずっとツイッターけれど
一回見たことあるぞそれ漱石生撮りするって麻生そうそうあれの twitter に
当たっ結構ツイッターでずーっとユーチューブみたいなことでよって youtube
はじめねーよはじめ根本表紙生まれてきて消化
ん
うやすごいよ本当に
一番みたいなね本当に魔女イケイケなか本当にいえいえ
自分で言うのはあれシャツ岡部てるああああああっ
ブーブー県から出たくない
おっな人がちょっと苦手ブーバーしかめっちゃサティロスあのんだ全然単著誕生日の
とき抜けきらいーけどっ
いやいいんだけど
飲んだと次の日がきついなるんだろうそうだろうどんなときはてませんだよねどんぐり
出っ張るやーもうこれいったらもう
これいく
こいつはいけません持つ俺ことはこれって頭に30本や言えばけれどいざ10%つは
猛獣ちゃダメ何やってたんですか
youtube やる前はあですね社長言ってました
普通に会社に撮った普通に感謝ですが普通にするとで社長をやっていい g a はじめ
だけ
d 住所と言うというさあスペインプールの中で佐藤選手を大々的にはそう
なんで社長ですよ
えっとね大学の時に学生で企業会社につなげたいなと思って
ふざけて飛ばすって言うじゃん100円でちょっと
じゃあでもね結局しなかったせんかったぞただや薬でキマッててさんだけに社長だった
からそういうことそれで謎美紗緒
エランの会社をするかも決めずにたそうそう沿っ会を作ったらかっこいいのだけれど
おおこのパリピアノよくしゃべりあって言ってるっていうかよ
いよいよ結局が実際に寝始めて今日は寝始め者だったけどね思ったので回ね
a feather どうぞどうぞ
う
デカい件女願いである版と反撃してこないはずあー
意外とこいつで道義性攻撃タイマーもちろんね本当にいいヤツだからほんとはね
ちょっと
うって意外と同じですこの1位該当するしないじゃないでしょちょっとまれてあるよね
dg 社長なんかちゃんとしてる奴説明はっはっは
狛江損じゃなく前こっち仕事今回あるよ
知らねえよちゃんとくっていうか麻雀っとこっち
卍卍ええええっ
分子のしっかりのすると言うよ
鏡子の家サーチにして帰っがレメロンズームドライバーん勢社長日福岡市駿河区
さあ優子が自身からちょいばとでちょっと4ゲーム売ってる短い看取るを言ってるぞ
思って思ったねねんねしとるそうそうなのは終了ッッッンは感慨といえばさぁ
ブラックカラー
[音楽]
ブーブーを見せ言ってたと思ういっやーかま0才パー皆さんはなんかキロスって持って
何の情報力
dodo 作ります
外観けどあっ反転にず[ __ ]でしょっぱいで俺生卵いっぱい頼んでた後ないですけど
ただ後3つられるとうわぁ解きまくっでそれことでその後にクラブに行っタイプそして
えぴょんパックもしろ馬鹿やったら食べちゃいました母みたいな汗この爺さんが言っ
あれっ
市単独そう思いけどまた食いたくなるパ
なるほどねうんじゃあお得でなりたいそうそうけっけこれたように産経ってそこの
ポーンさん書いて送ったらなんだかんだ何か言われたら確かに言ったらじゃあこれを
持っちゃう肇社長のチャンネルでどこまでしゃべっているマイルに何でも言って山路
何でもいいと思ったことでおっ
またね逆に非課金さとめちゃめちゃきた趣味やスカラジエーターが凄い凄いよイーター
度
神かみ本当にを流鏑馬だったら俺らちゃん何でもするねうんけぐぐーぜんぜん
さーさーああちょっとみんな気になるほどひどいついてみますか伺いましたに気になる
ほど
はじめ者さんのことをどう思っていますから
どーん思っとったがいなくなら混ぜ市場が痛かったと本当にそれは本気本気本気本気
ません
ええええ
会えて嬉39めっちゃたか今日もめっちゃ
本当にもうシンブルにめっちゃ嬉しいほんとさん
と思います今はこんなナマズ類ことだって黒
すぎだったら凄いことですよなぁこれはもうほぼ次の次回予告みたいなところあるんで
ねもう面になっちゃいますね氏ねまじ正解は言わなかってこれ俺のある試合は祝うああ
ああああっ雑音のことなんてよかなーっ本名は鬼もどき妄想アティ
はぁ派いやーちょっとパーテラー全然大丈夫
全然取り始めた既存な動きちゃったっけええあああやー
手帳俺にラップをしてくれらっぷ募集中ラップしてねーはじめ
俺は
跳馬するはの味道前ローバー今日は価値ねえねえからは険しいでなんとかとうううっ
だじゃあレペゼン地球のいいところはなぁ
こうヤバイことやってます全面的に出しているのはすぐハァハァ
ぞ
実際ちょっと酔っぱらった米や全然よく絡んだり
像がいい奴だよね良かったなあ本当になろうじゃないじゃないじゃないでしょ
悪い朝までやれやれこのあとあの髪の毛むしろと思っておきほんとやめて同じ社長の名
を継ぐ者同士て言いますかポテンシャルがあって俺すごいですけどああっああ
余裕これ飯食ってるねーあっほ
神戸目標は
これはゆっペイチャンネル登録一銭の金本位の場合言うけど誰よりも早く来てるなの
だろうね俺以来今160万円でな100
オーライごじゅうぶんっで開けさんも700枚それ以外のすごい
例えば300万とか4100万とか200万とか乗ったと取って誰よりも早く
一銭も入った
家みたいなんだろうけど
版が濃い廃盤サーガまた食い出しませこうよ
数え始め社長程度バーサーク700戻すだいぶきつや
ぶりぶりぶりではめっちゃきついけどちゃってくださ思ういいからさ
youtube さ考え方がアメリカすぎ議員のたて誰
いいなと10万でこれ
って嘘いきなり100万出すねそう10万円としたチョチョってもさん100枚別
めっちゃ少ないちょっとって日したら大嫌い200枚なのに
次の大学もさせ2位一戦毎目標設定みなさーん何かあっ-10
アーサーは1000万円ですよねー日本人10人にしてやはり登録者や本当に貴重
9人のうちのクラスでは8日ないと700万すごいでね結構やばいそれは責任感はれる
れいなそうなんだよね俺だったら社長にね youtube 大先輩としてアドバイス
できるだったら難しいんだけど上手い子だったも使って降板されないようにしていくの
が大事ですよねを支えにも行く食らってるからさ
プラシーであれ i 血統は振動がってやっぱ
最近厳しいを厳しいメッツ dj 見せたよ
あーそんな彼でも何とかしてほしいというのが取れるのが新聞クリエイターかなって
思うんですか
おいらも本当はよ裸で走るよいいけど
ねあー難しいところあるんだけど頑張ってるわけなんですよチューバー
そう言いながら今日さっきここで下を張って言ってるんだっけもん大介ねよくいう考え
がすごい祭神ぽよ好きだねぇ
ゲージさ超好きなんか好きなポケモンなんですか
[音楽]
ルーンパパへへー
me
ni
こんなぞうんさわやかハンバーグでハンバーグ食べに行くを食べよう
よろしくが欲しい号し切開し条件ちゃうね反対声音とあん馬ルーム